las vegas entertainment and nightlife
we've been profiling it for weeks it's
about to be back in a big way
and of course the upcoming holiday
weekend only the beginning
editor at large brock bradke of las
vegas weekly is joining us
now via skype or zoom there he is
brock okay this is a definite indication
that las vegas is back in business
and this must have been such a nice
change for you putting this spread
together compared to memorial day of
last year huh
yeah it was nice to have a lot of things
to talk about instead of nothing to talk
about
absolutely i bet all right let's talk
pool parties maybe a little out of our
age range brock but people love them and
vegas certainly does them up in style
right
definitely uh all of the major pool
parties and day clubs are going to be
open
this memorial day weekend of course
they're not necessarily open to full
capacity yet
you're not going to see the big
headlining djs come in that's gonna
happen
the following weekend but there's a lot
more venues open day and night and a lot
more entertainment events happening so
we should be able to
satisfy all these extra visitors that
we're gonna have coming into town this
weekend
certainly and you know resorts world
opening up june
24th we've been so excited about that
seems everyone is
the first major resort to open on the
las vegas strip
since the cosmopolitan opened in 2010
and they've got
incredible headliners don't they
they do they've been creating a lot of
buzz with their their big foursome of
headliners uh
celine dion katy perry carrie underwood
and luke bryan and all four of them
in the last week have added additional
show dates
to their residency shows and they're
going to start in november with celine
but
that happened before the regular on
sales even happened so there's a lot of
demand for big
live entertainment in las vegas it's
incredible another six that i think
carrie's adding it's wonderful and
they're excited for these residencies
here too because
you know they've got young kids they
don't want to be all over the country
they want to be able to hunker down so
i've heard they're quite excited about
that we know some other familiar names
are back at their home venues
yeah that's right the big the the first
resident to come back is going to be
bruno mars
at park mgm uh that's going to happen
around
4th of july weekend but then after that
you've got george strait coming back to
t-mobile arena
and you've got lionel richie and john
fogarty at wynn las vegas
and then just announced this morning
shania twain is coming back to
zappos theater at planet hollywood gwen
stefani is going to be there
as well in a few months oh it's so much
fun lionel richie's awesome too
all right well thank you brock it's so
nice to touch base and
you know in the not too distant future
maybe we'll get you back in studio
looking forward to those
interviews as well i'm ready you say
when i'll be there
all right thanks brock take care